oh hi chris kohler of wired com here at
e3 2009 as always with Chris Baker of
Wired magazine we just got finished
watching Electronic Arts press
conference EA is no longer the number
one developer or publisher in the video
games industry that honor now belongs to
Activision but EA was really trying to
put on a big show at impress us what did
you think Chris yeah you know good solid
broad line up from EA it's a huge
company you know they have their Sims
division we saw a bit of sims 3 which is
launching today it's uh kids games you
know a little bit of everything what EA
showed generally could be broken down
into three big categories they showed a
lot of kids games which we're not really
going to bore you with right now but the
second thing that they showed was EA
sports sports obviously big big category
for Electronic Arts historically they
really wanted to show that they're still
dominant they showed us some interesting
new features for NCAA football some
interesting new features for madden but
what i thought was was especially
interesting was the fact they talked
about EA sports active for the wii peter
moore the president of EA sports said
that EA has actually sold over 600,000
copies already of EA sports active and
the downloadable content and expansion
pack is going to be on the way for the
wii version of that game and there was
also something else right well there was
a we saw a new tennis game for Wii
what's a cone Oh grand slam tennis yeah
sort of abstract stylized characters
rather than the photo realistic
characters you see any a sports other
games but it's actually takes place in
Wimbledon real cartoony versions of real
tennis stars Pete Sampras was actually
there to show it off ladies gentlemen 14
tying grand slam champion Pete Sampras
so yeah I do need some help
it's how does this feel pain relation to
the real Wimbledon this is easier this
is easier oh yes the actual real-life
version of Pete Sampras played as the
the cartoon version of Pete Sampras uses
the wii's motion plus controller in fact
the motion plus add-on for the wii that
gives the wii greater motion sensitivity
is going to be bundled in first with
some of Electronic Arts games before
getting bundled in with a Nintendo game
later on in the year after sports
Electronic Arts talked about the EA
Partners Program which has been a really
big hit for them EA partners is where EA
goes out and they partner up with a
great video game developers releasing
really interesting original content rock
band beatles is an EA partners game but
some other EA partners games were
actually announced here APB all points
bulletin the big big online game from
the guys who brought us crackdown is
going to be published by EA yeah that
one looks really interesting it's a sort
of imagine a hundred player version of
crackdown co-op a hundred of you let
loose in this city and you can become
criminal gang lords you can become good
guide vigilantes but basically all of
you duking out and battling for control
of this city how can you not be excited
about that another biggie a partners
game was Star Wars The Old Republic a
massively multiplayer online star wars
game being co-developed by EA company
Bioware and of course lucasarts on the
way out I heard a lot of people say that
they would trust Bioware the developer
to make the next Star Wars movie instead
of Lucas film because they are so good
at nailing no character and story and we
saw a very impressive CG cutscene that
will be in the game and also learned
that the game will feature only spoken
dialogue to put this in perspective we
believe this could be one of the largest
voiceover projects in the history of
games and maybe across all areas of
entertainment and the older public there
are hundreds of thousands of lines of
dialogue and thousands of speaking roles
most MMOs still feature a lot of
text-based dialogue just because there
is there are so many characters so many
people you can talk to so many possible
things
and say and the commitment to this
enormous task of making every bit of
dialogue in the game spoken kind of
shows Bioware's commitment to story yeah
if you like if you like story in your in
your MMOs star wars the old republic is
probably going to be one that you're
definitely going to want to play
so something else i really liked I mean
obviously I love brutal legend game by
double fine productions going to star
Jack Black we've covered it quite a bit
they showed a brand-new trailer a little
comedy sketch with Jack Black during the
show you have footage of the game why
the hell did I drill a freaking hole in
my skull I thought it'd be funny but I
think he gave yourself brain damage my
telephone is fine shoelaces go by
bruegel leg bone
this guitar blues kampung we also
learned some of the characters and the
games are going to be voiced by some
heavy metal royalty with rob halford the
other guy is gonna be a bloodbath ooh
what is that smell is a Bernie hair let
me kill Meister now what the hell Rita
for would you like a ride
ozzy osbourne it's about bigger
with all these varying games being shown
at the a press conference what was your
favorite well I would have to go with
littlest pets online it they say it's
only for 9 to 12 year old girls but
there's a little something in that game
for everyone I'm going to be borrowing
and say brutal legend I think brutal
legend was my favorite game of the show
but I was plenty to choose from
Electronic Arts is definitely capturing
a wide audience